(jet engine)
- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan; my one word is believe.
And I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself,
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
I started the Believe Life series
to help us learn a little
bit more about ourselves,
grow personally,
and ideally bring some of
what we learn about ourselves
to our business to have more success.
So today we're going to learn
how to motivate yourself.
Rule number four is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys liked the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down
in the comments below,
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple of hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
- [Female] We're all given
a certain amount of time
to experience life.
To carry out our dreams, our destiny.
But we don't realize that
the time bar of our life
can only grow smaller
from today going forward.
Let that sink in.
You can't buy time, you can't grow time.
You can't ask for more time.
You can only lose time.
And after we lose time,
we have no idea how much
time we even have left.
Our lifespan is a mystery.
See, being human is a double-edged sword
because although we have
so much time compared
to other species,
we give ourselves too much time
to accomplish what needs to be done.
The idea of having so much
more time to accomplish things
makes us waste time.
We abuse it.
It feeds our lack of action,
it makes us too comfortable.
Now we all aim to succeed, to prosper,
to become a diamond in
a world full of rocks.
But there's no evolutionary
pressure to help us.
And that's where the mind
shift needs to take place.
You need to create a pressure for yourself
to become that diamond.
And the way that you do that
is by understanding the value of time.
Stop killing time.
Because eventually that turns around,
and time is going to kill you.
You have the power to prevent time loss.
You have the power to prevent wasted time.
But you also have the power to kill time,
and many of us are doing that.
Before we make decisions, before we act,
we need to think about how
we're spending our time.
We need to focus on what
we want to accomplish.
What makes the heart burn with passion?
What wakes us up in the morning?
What's your why?
Time is the most valuable
resource we have.
I can save money for later.
I can't do that with my time.
I can invest in more money,
I can't do that with time.
I can share my money.
I still can't do that with time.
Stop damaging your lifespan.
Sooner or later, you're going to realize
that the only thing you wish
you have more of is time.
But it's what you use the worst.
(Upbeat music)
- Let me tell you something.
The M, your motives.
Listen to me.
When you get to a point
where you start living certain thing,
you ain't got to say it.
You ain't got to be a
walking billboard, right.
People will know who you are,
not by what you say, or claim you are.
But they'll know who
you are by your spirit.
Are you hearing what I'm saying?
And that's my last one,
motive, what's your motive?
There are a lot of people,
you're not successful in life
not because you ain't got talent,
not because you ain't got skills,
but your character ain't right.
And I told you this before,
that if you're not careful your
talent would take you places
that your character can't keep you.
Are you hearing what I'm saying?
Your talent will take you places,
your character can't keep you.
So what's your motive?
There are people out
there who call me E.T.,
I want to be a speaker.
Why?
You trying to blow up?
You trying to be C?
Or are you trying to help people?
Are you trying to minister to people?
Are you trying to help
people in their life,
or are you trying to blow up?
Alright, so somebody came
into my life the other day
and told me they want to be famous.
I said what you want to be famous at?
They like, "I dunno what
I want to be famous in.
I just want to be able
to walk through the mall,
and they shut it down."
Listen to me, what's your motive?
Why do you do what you do?
And that's so important.
It's not enough just to be a doctor.
You got doctors who got terrible
bedside manners, terrible.
You got lawyers who are
skilled but arrogant.
We talking about character right now.
What's your motive?
Why do you do what you do?
Are you doing what you're
doing to help people,
to benefit people?
You say E.T., you ain't
trying to get paid.
Listen to me very closely.
Look, when you good at what you do,
and you looking out for people;
are you hearing what I'm saying?
Listen to me, I crack codes.
I've been able to get into places
other people don't get into.
Why?
Because people understand,
they understand that E.T.;
we know why he do what he doing.
E.T. is trying to help us, not hurt us.
Are you hearing me?
And so, I'm going to
let you listen to this.
I'm going to let you listen to the why.
We took it down from the site.
I'm going to put it
back up, just the audio.
I want you to listen to
it, but before we go.
Remember the I in idea, that's good.
A, action, that's important.
But the motivation is important.
Why?
Because when you look at
the word you got two things,
you got motive and then action, right?
So motive is important because
what's driving your action.
Hear what I'm saying.
Even in your action,
why your action is good.
You've got to ask what drives it,
what guides it, what moves it,
what's the spirit behind it,
what's the reason behind it,
what's the purpose behind it?
Are you hearing what I'm saying?
That's just as critical
as the action itself.
So the reason why you can't
get up at four o'clock
in the morning, the reason
why when I say get up at six,
you're looking at me like I'm crazy,
is because you don't have
that thing that's driving you,
that's pushing you to say
no to the alarm clock.
And wake up.
No to the snooze button.
When you get that extra
assignment, that extra lap.
The reason why you can't do it,
is because you don't have the right oomph.
You ain't got the right oomph.
That motive that's pushing the action.
And so I want you to listen to the why,
and at the end of it I
want you to write down
what motivates you.
And when you write it
down, if it's just money,
listen to me Boo.
If it's just money you going to make it,
and then what's going to happen?
Right?
If it's just to be C,
if it's just about you.
When you get in the gated community,
when you get that European vehicle,
when you blow up, what's that?
What do you do after that?
Are you hearing me?
If you make it to the NFL,
and that's only a three year span,
ten years at most.
If you make it to the NBA, and you retire,
and you're still 32,
33, what's after that?
So what you made it to the league.
So what you won a championship.
So what you the MVP.
So what you won the scoring title.
What's after that?
So what you got the Lombardi trophy.
So what you got the rushing title.
So what you got the most
runs, the most yards in NFL.
What's after that?
So what's your motivation?
What moves you?
What drives you?
And you'll hear me say it,
Martin Luther King died,
I don't know how much money he made,
but I know his motivation.
He moved the world.
I don't know how much
money Mother Theresa made,
but I know she changed the world.
I don't know how much money Gandhi made,
but I know he changed the world.
What's your why?
- A lot of people think they'll
have motivation one day,
then they'll put the effort out.
It's like motivation first, they think,
then effort comes.
The motivation inspires the effort, right?
It's actually the opposite
in the science of motivation.
It's with daily effort,
that motivation comes.
I like to tell people this.
With momentum, comes more motivation.
Don't wait for the motivation
to go out and take action.
Actually, take action first,
'cause just a little bit of
progress, a few quick wins
drops dopamine into the brain.
We start feeling good and
rewarded for our behavior.
And suddenly we find
ourselves more motivation.
So here's the thing.
Set three goals each day.
Knock off each of those three goals.
If you just did that,
each and every single day,
you'd start feeling more personal power,
and you'd start getting ahead.
- I started shaving my head
when I was 16 years old.
And the feeling I had every morning,
I looked in the mirror was horrible.
And I didn't want to
feel like that anymore.
And how I felt was a kid going nowhere,
a kid that was scared.
And most kids will accept
that and look for help.
But the best thing that happened to me
no one helped me.
No one felt sorry for me.
No one looked at me and
said, like this day and age,
they'll take you in and
they'll tell everybody to
stop picking on this person.
Back then they didn't care.
The KKK marched in our
4th of July parades.
They had to stay 100 yards back,
but they marched in it.
That's how this town was.
And my mom cared about me,
but my dad took our soul.
She did the best she could.
I had to figure out,
I wasn't going to be a
punk kid all my life.
So the only way I could turn
it around, was to suffer.
I had to build calluses in my brain,
the same way I built calluses on my hands.
So I broke the Guinness
Book of World Records
for pull-ups a long time ago.
But I failed at it twice.
And I did 67,000 pull-ups in
trying to break this record.
So to do 4,030 pull-ups,
I had to do 67,000 for training for that.
- Wow.
- And so, what I realized
is for me to become the
man I wanted to become,
I saw myself as the weakest
person God ever created,
but I never blamed God
for anything he did to me.
So I wanted to change that
to be the hardest man ever created.
Am I that?
I don't know, but he had to have a goal.
And my goal, when I was sitting
there not going to school,
being bullied, having no
self-esteem, my goal was,
the only person that's going to
turn this person around is me.
The only way I can turn it around
is put myself through the
worst things possible,
a human being can ever endure.
And that would be the only way
that I can build this brain
to handle anything that
comes in front of it.
callusing my mind through
pain and suffering.
- In the end, like, what
would your advice be
to that 16 year old kid
who's staring in the mirror,
does not like what he sees,
but is still running from adversity?
- Well my biggest advice to him is that,
first of all, he won't
like what I say to him.
Because I'm going to say the
exact opposite of what the world,
today's world is saying.
So we read a bunch of books nowadays.
As humans, we want to find
out how to be someone else.
What we don't do, we don't go inside.
So literally turn yourself inside out.
Read the book that's;
like we're writing a book
every day of our lives, but
we never read that book.
So what I would challenge this young man,
or young woman to do,
is you have to look inside of yourself
to see what you really want.
What are you passionate about?
We use these words and
these little phrases of
only the strong survive,
and all this other crap.
They're all just (expletive) words.
I get so tired of hearing
people just talking.
Like right now, someone might
think Doggin's just talking.
You don't know me.
So when I speak I speak from passion,
I speak from experience,
I speak from suffering.
I would have to tell
this young man or woman
that the only way, I believe;
and this is my experience in life.
The only way you're ever
going to get to the other side
of this journey, is you
have got to suffer to grow.
To grow, you must suffer.
And some people get it,
and some people won't.
But they have to see
what their journey is,
to start their journey.
Several people live to be 100 years old,
and they have great lives,
and they have great kids.
Their kids go to college,
and all sort of other stuff.
But somewhere in their life,
there was a point where
they had a decision to make.
They can go left or right on this path.
Left was the easy route,
right was the hard route.
A lot of people take the easy route.
And they had a good life that way,
but the better life was
going to the right side.
And you may have 20 years
of pain and suffering to get past it,
but a lot of us die never
truly starting our journey.
And I would tell this young person,
you've got to start your journey.
It may suck, but it will
come out the other side
where you're coasting.
- If you find your passion,
you're going to have
this tremendous energy,
a sustainable energy.
But momentum requires you
always do the next thing
to keep the momentum going.
And the reason you get
yourself in a passionate place,
is so that you change your life.
And the only thing that changes your life
is making a decision.
So while you're in this passionate state,
that's when you make decisions.
You don't make decisions when you're like,
I don't know, what do you
think, alright let's decide.
If you make a decision in
a state without momentum,
if you make a decision from a place
where there's no passion,
you are not going to get momentum.
It'll kill momentum.
It's decide, commit, and resolve.
Some of you,
in the past you've gotten momentum.
You've gotten passionate.
You've even made a decision,
but a decision is the first step.
Decision is like a war.
I got to do this or that.
Alright I'm going to make myself do this.
But commitment is when you
now, after you've decided
you commit to do this for the long term.
Whether it's hard or easy doesn't
matter, you're doing this.
It takes it from this moment,
and it carries it into the future,
even when things are difficult.
And the third state is resolve.
Resolve means it's done.
It's like, it doesn't
even if you take action,
it's done inside you,
so it's done out there.
There's no question whatsoever.
Then once you decide,
the only way the
commitment, and the energy,
and the momentum continues,
is if you take immediate,
massive, what my friends?
Massive what?
Write down in your notes,
massive action is the cure all.
Massive action is the cure all.
If you're having a difficult
time with something,
your relationship isn't
where you want it to be,
your finances are not
where you want to be,
your body's not where you want to be,
your business is not
where you want it to be.
You need to take massive action.
And if that doesn't
work, try something else.
If that doesn't work, try something else.
Keep going with massive action,
and you will find the way
because it will give you momentum.
- How do we get people
to become success seekers
rather than failure avoiders?
First day of introductory
psychology class,
I teach two classes of 600 students.
Maybe some of you have been in that class.
And remember, the first day I say,
how many are here to avoid failure?
And 80% raise their hand.
And I say, well thanks for coming.
I know you're motivated, but
you're not happy campers.
You probably told your
friends I got to go to class,
it's a requirement.
Not, I get to go to class,
it's an opportunity.
You probably woke up to an alarm clock,
not an opportunity clock.
And it's all in how you see it.
Really, it's all in how you see it.
It's your paradigm.
It's how you communicate to others,
and how you communicate to yourself.
So Ellen Langer said in
her book Mindfulness.
She said, and psychologists know,
when you perceive choice,
you perceive motivation.
You're more motivated.
So the deal is, for yourself,
sit back and reflect.
Be mindful of the choices you have.
And talk about being a success seeker,
rather than a failure avoider.
It's all how you talk, how
you communicate to yourself,
and to others.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to apply immediately,
somehow to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to hear from you.
And if you leave a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you might win one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a
shout out to Jmiah Expose.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, the eBook
version, and reading it
and sharing it to your audience.
I really, really appreciate the support,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(jet engine)
- [Male] The biggest thing
you should fear in your life
is that you waste your life.
This precious thing that you've got.
This one chance.
This one instance.
This one shot that you get.
Just one.
Do you realize what this life is?
I feel like people don't really understand
what life is.
I mean what is life?
Look at your hands.
Like look around you, it's
amazing, it's pure magic.
- [Male] The average guy,
he lacks the skills to do
anything productive in his life.
If he decides to take on
a new diet, he'll drop it.
He probably won't even
finish reading the diet book.
If he decides to go to the gym,
and he's tired after
he gets home from work,
he says I'm tired.
I am not going to the gym
today because I'm tired.
My emotions tell me not to go to the gym,
so I'm not going to the gym
because my emotions said so.
A lot of people simply
do not have standards.
They're willing to let their life slide.
They're willing to let
their life just ooze on by.
And they lack a sense of urgency
about the direction that
their life is going.
- [Male] Is what you want,
to live a nice happy life
with a simple family,
and a nine to five job,
and then retirement?
That is what you're going
to do with your one life?
- [Male] What are some examples
of things that are pathetic?
Not having your health
handled (expletive) pathetic.
Not living in a situation
that you're comfortable in
because you were lazy.
(expletive) pathetic.
And how about not having the type of
dating life that you want
or sex life that you want,
if you don't have that, it
is (expletive) pathetic.
- [Male] That's it?
That's what you're going to do?
You're going to go, you're
going to punch the clock,
for eight, nine hours a day,
for 40 years of your life.
Your work you have no
emotional connection to,
doing work that isn't serving
the universe or the world
in any especially important way.
And then you're going to do that
over and over and over again.
- [Male] So the reason why
people don't put action
behind their work, and
their thought process,
and what they're saying,
is because they lose the motivation.
They lose that fire inside.
- [Male] And beyond that, just what is,
what is this reality that we have?
It's like pure magic.
It really is.
And yet what do you do with it?
You (expletive) all over it.
You take this magical thing,
and what have you done with it.
You've made yourself bored and miserable,
and depressed, and
whining and complaining,
and bitching and moaning,
and acting the victim,
and being unmotivated, and being petty.
Worrying about stupid things,
holding negative judgements
and opinions of other.
Taking all of this for granted.
Imagine right now that I told you
that you only have til
the end of today to live.
- With every milestone,
while you might be excited
about the milestone,
there's a part of the milestone
that you don't want to face.
Are you hearing me?
And listen to me, I
knocked out the course.
Where boom, got it done.
In order.
E.T., why did it take you two years, E.T.,
after you finished your coursework,
why did it take you two
years to get started
with the dissertation?
I'm going to be 100 with you.
Look, knocked all the coursework out.
But when I finally got
to the dissertation,
I had to get to that demon.
I had to deal with it.
I had to face it.
Face what?
We not talking about elementary school,
middle school, high school.
I had a professor or
two tell me in college
that you will never get your dissertation.
That while your writing has improved,
but in terms of your analysis,
you are not critical enough
to do a dissertation.
Are you hearing what I'm telling you.
We talking about math,
I love math coming up.
Why?
It is what it is.
A please, excuse my dear, a (mumbles)
it is what it is.
It's not subjective.
Writing is subjective.
I've had teachers that look at my work
and strip it into parts.
The fear, the fear of what?
The fear of rejection.
Right?
My teachers were so (mumbles).
I put my whole heart into it.
I put everything I could put.
And they tell me, edit it again.
A revision after
revision, edit after edit.
Are you hearing what I'm telling you?
I had to deal with the fact
that writing has never
really been my strong suit.
And even though I worked hard,
and I put in hours and hours,
in the back of my mind;
in the back of my mind I
could hear the teachers say,
"E.T. you don't have what it
takes to get a dissertation."
I'm a grown man dealing with that fear.
I'm a grown man and
dealing with the rejection
of getting all that red;
all that red on my paper.
Of having to do it over and
over, and over and over.
And c'mon, c'mon somebody feels me.
You feel like you will do 120%,
you'll give everything you have
and it still won't be enough.
I feel you.
I was there.
A part of the milestone here is,
what if I give everything
and it ain't enough?
What if I put my whole
heart, my whole mind,
my whole soul into it
E.T., and it's not enough?
What if I do it and I fail?
And so I feel you.
So you just like you not
going to do it at all
because you'd rather not do
it and find out the truth.
And I'm telling you, you
got to do me a favor.
You got to face your fear,
and you got to do it anyway.
Your boy E.T. had to face his fear.
That's right, yup, I know
you see E.T., beast mode.
And you right, I am beast mode,
but it don't mean beast mode without fear.
It don't mean beast mode
without a little anxiety.
It don't mean beast mode,
and I'm just 120% sure.
No, I have to live by faith too.
And I made up in my mind, E.T.
you've got to go after it, E.
Look I finished my coursework.
It took me two years, why?
'Cause it took me two
years to get over the fear.
It took me two years to
get over the anxiety.
It took me two years to finally
say Goliath, here I come.
Goliath you might be taller than me,
you might be bigger than me,
you might be stronger than me.
But I'm coming, and I'd rather die trying.
I'd rather die going
after this dissertation.
I'd rather give everything I got;
I'd rather give a year.
I'd rather put in work and fail,
than not try at all.
- You have to focus.
Now before you turn off the
video or go to the next one,
listen to this.
A lot of people have that initial desire,
but they don't look at their
goals every single day.
They don't revisit every
single, like say Sunday,
and say how did I do this week.
How did I do in my health,
in my relationships,
in my career?
How did I do with my finances?
How did I do with any
other goals that I set up?
You have to have that daily discipline
to look and focus on what you're doing,
and that weekly review.
You also have to have the
ability to avoid distractions.
One of the reasons people love my book,
The Motivation Manifesto,
is this teaches you how to set boundaries,
how to say no,
how to push away distraction
to own your life again.